(Jordan laughing)
- Lil Wayne, y'all.
The Carter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ain't I a stinker.
♪ All I want yea ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪
- All right. You're doing fine, sweetie.
Now, Malia,
let's just go easy on the gas here,
and come to a complete stop.
- Hey!
- Okay. So in the future,
you want to try not to
go through stop signs.
(car tires squealing)
(police siren wailing)
Okay. Just remain calm now,
and what you're going to want to do
is pull up right here next to the curb.
This is why we want to stay in the lines,
and we want to follow rules.
Remember this.
- License and registration.
Holy...
Mr. President.
- Yeah, yeah, just teaching
Malia to drive here.
- Well you guys ran a
stop sign back there,
but that's okay. You can go.
- Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Malia's got to learn
what it's like to drive
in the real world here.
This is called consequences, Malia.
Now I want you to go ahead
and treat us like you would
if I weren't the President.
(body slamming)
Not exactly what I had in mind.
Thank you, and may God bless America.
(audience clapping)
- All right, this way.
A couple of introductions and
we'll get you out of here.
This is John O'Rourke.
- Nice to meet you John.
- [Man] Mr. Ian Roberts.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Man] Peter Atencio.
- All right. Nice to meet you.
- [Man] Jerome Smith.
- Come on, brother. What's up fam?
You know this.
- [Man] Keith Williamson.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Man] Mary Woodbury.
- [Man] Jay Martel.
- Nice to meet you sir.
- [Man] Tasha Robbins.
- Come on, come on, come on.
Feel that?
- [Man] Emily George.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Man] Darryl Stokes.
- Come on.
What's up fam? How you doing?
- All right.
- Never forget about that,
cause that's all we got.
- Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
All right.
Aw, bring it in, bring it in.
Started from the bottom, now we here.
- Yeah.
- Nice to meet you.
All right.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to...
- One eighth black.
- Afternoon my octoroon.
Come on, bring it in there. Tuck that.
- I'm in it, dog.
- You tucking it in there?
Let your tuck go.
- I'm tucked.
I'm in there.
- All right.
Nice to meet you, man.
Nice to meet you.
Oh my goodness.
Look at this.
Oh.
She is so beautiful.
Mmm (smacks lips)
I want another one.
There you go.
Precious. Beautiful. Beautiful.
What's her name?
- This is Livia Roogey.
- Mkay. Nice to meet you, Ms. Roogey.
All right.
Come on.
There he is.
Boom.
- Mr. President.
All right man, good to meet you.
- [Man] Here we go.
Right this way, sir.
(sensual music)
- Oh,
(Jordan chuckling)
Hi.
That, wasn't, expecting to see
you all undulating up here?
Hi. I just put my jacket on the bed
when I first came to the party,
but I didn't realize that the
party made its way up here,
but I'll get that now. I will.
If you, Carol, I don't know
if you're in there somewhere,
but wherever you are, thank
you for the invitation.
I really enjoyed myself.
I'll see you at work tomorrow.
Okay, hey sir,
I think I see my jacket.
I think your arm is in
the sleeve, actually.
I'll grab, that's not my
jacket and that's not your arm.
It's not your arm.
White people are crazy.
Just looking for a jacket, sir.
Okay. Yeah.
Very nice mustache. I've
never seen one above the nose.
That's interesting.
That's not your nose. Okay.
Sorry to disturb you sir.
Just looking for a jacket.
Just a ordinary man looking for jacket.
You want to say something to me, sir?
Are you, oh.
Nope. Thank you very much, sir.
It tasted a little bit
like salted butt (beep)
but that's okay.
It's tweed. The jacket I'm talking about.
And it's got leather patches on it.
Just, oh, maybe this is it.
Thank you. Found it.
And nope, that's not it.
But congratulations, ma'am.
You are doing great
with what God gave you.
Nope. Don't look at me in the eyes, ma'am.
I don't want you to steal my soul.
Hi ladies, nice to meet you. And sir.
Yes, I do see you too.
Okay. Yes.
White people are crazy.
Oh no, I'm okay. I really am.
I'm already seeing a group of people
and we're taking it slowly.
We are taking it slowly.
It's a church.
Maybe some of y'all would be interested in
looking into that.
Not mine, but one, somewhere. If that's--
Okay, thank you ma'am for, there it is.
I found it. Found the jacket.
It's right here.
I'm going to pull it
and I believe it might be
lodged somewhere within ya.
I'm just guessing,
because that is just a
little bit of resistance.
All right. There we go.
And you know what? That
is going to be yours.
Keep it. Thank you.
Cover yourself up.
Carol. If you're in there,
I'll see you at the office tomorrow.
Just bring the bowl.
You can finish the egg salad.
My God, white people cray.
(air whooshing)
(gentle music)
- Now, first, let me just
say that I'm encouraged
that so many of you from
the Republican Party
have agreed to meet me in this way.
Now as you know,
I've tried very hard to
reach across the aisle,
govern this country from the middle.
- Well, all due respect, Mr. President,
we disagree with you.
- We think you should
run the country from...
not the middle.
- Well, that's why we're here.
If you would,
I'd just appreciate some
feedback on some new ideas
and directions for this country.
Feel free to agree or disagree,
whatever you want.
- We're gonna disagree.
- [Republican] Disagree.
- Disagree.
- [Republican] Disagree
- First, I think the
government is too big.
I think we need to shrink the
size of the federal government
so that all decisions can
be made at the state level.
- We disagree, Mr. President.
- You drive a hard bargain.
You win.
(Republican leaders laughing)
- There we go.
- Big government it is.
Next up, this has been a hot button issue,
but I think we can settle it right here.
No taxes for rich people.
- We completely disagree.
- Round two goes to you guys.
- Okay.
- More taxes for the rich.
- What the (beep).
- What is happening to us?
- Man, I am taking a beating here guys.
All right. Last issue, immigration.
Now, we need to secure our borders,
and anybody who's here illegally
should be hunted down and deported.
(Republican stammering)
- We disagree.
(paper rustling)
(tape crackling)
- We are a country of immigrants.
No!
- We need a clear path to citizenship
for all of those who are already here.
Help me!
(scissors cutting)
(Republicans groaning)
(heads slamming table)
- Great.
I love your ideas.
Lastly, we can not regulate firearms.
- Yes we can.
Yes we can!
(Republicans crying)
- All right. All right.
If you guys say so.
And nobody better throw me a cigarette.
Ain't I a stinker.
(triumphant music)
(hip hop music)
(police sirens wailing)
- All y'all rappers out there,
you think y'all hard cause
what y'all been through?
Hey yo, check it out.
♪ It was Friday night
chilling on my front lawn. ♪
♪ Me and my crew I had my bathrobe on ♪
♪ Everybody high just watched X Men ♪
♪ Got plenty chicken
heads ready for sex man. ♪
♪ Busters roll up they
trying to talk smack ♪
♪ Don't these (beep) know
they (beep) with the Mack ♪
♪ Two police nod I knew homie seen us ♪
♪ He pulled two shots somehow
my penis got between us ♪
♪ I got shot through the (beep) ♪
♪ Shot shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ I got shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ But his (beep) still standing ♪
♪ Shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ Shot shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ I got shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ But his (beep) still standing ♪
(gun shots firing)
♪ Went back to my palace fast ♪
♪ Now I'm the dude walking
round with a phallus cast ♪
♪ Like Wolverine I'm
trying to be a loner ♪
♪ But they think a (beep)
got an adamantium boner ♪
♪ What can I say ♪
♪ They still up on my totem pole ♪
♪ Bitch get your tongue ring
away from the scrotum hole ♪
♪ Don't know why they love it ♪
♪ But it keeps the ladies moistening ♪
♪ Gave half the honeys in
the hood lead poisoning ♪
♪ Shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ Shot shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ I got shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ But his (beep) still standing ♪
♪ Shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ Shot shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ I got shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ But his (beep) still standing ♪
♪ La la la la la la ♪
- Yo. They shot that fool in the (beep).
- God she (beep) man.
Damn, that hurts.
Damn no, video over man, video's over.
(bell ringing)
I'm serious, man.
Damn.
(air whooshing)
Hey girl. I'm home.
- Hey boo. How you doing?
- Good.
- How was work?
- It sucked.
- Aw. Can I ask you a quick question?
- Yeah sure. What up?
- I just been noticing that
every time I leave to go out,
the next time I open the computer,
the browser history has been cleared.
- Hmm.
That's weird.
- Yesterday I went food
shopping for like 15 minutes.
I used the computer before
I went to the store,
and when I came back,
my history was gone,
the cache was cleared,
and the cookies have been reset.
- Huh.
(suspenseful music)
Well, I think sometimes
the computer runs an
automatic software update,
so maybe that just kind
of clears the history.
- Yeah. Except when you
update the software,
a little window pops
up and you click okay,
and then it gets installed. So.
- Hmm.
(suspenseful music)
I dunno, maybe there's something
wrong with the computer,
you know?
And it's just one of those things,
whenever it gets interrupted
from the power source,
it has to reboot and it just
totally wipes out the history.
- Be honest babe.
It's porn, right?
- Porn? What's?
Oh, pornography?
No.
- It's okay if you look at
porn, I assumed you did anyways.
I mean, every guy does.
I'm perfectly okay with that.
As long as it's not that weird stuff.
Oh.
All right. Well, I mean kinky is okay.
I like kinky.
As long as it's not that
sick twisted S and M stuff.
Wow.
Um...
Okay. I'm not going to judge your journey.
It is your fantasy,
just as long as you're
looking at women who--
Not women?
Wow.
Okay.
Men?
Chicks with dicks?
Horses?
Worse than horses?
Wow.
- Baby, give me a little credit.
None of that matters.
The only thing that matters
that when we're doing it,
I'm thinking about you,
and you're thinking about me, right?
Right, baby?
(suspenseful music)
- There you go.
Excuse me.
Oh, excuse me, sir.
Are you sitting in 26G?
- Yes.
Have I done something wrong?
- No, no, no, no.
We just wanted to ask if you
would mind switching seats
so that a mother and a
child could sit together.
- But...
I'm back there.
- Right, yeah. But you'd
actually be sitting here,
(harp playing)
which is in economy plus.
It's actually an upgrade.
- Upgrade, you say?
- Mm-hmm.
- Economy plus?
- Yes, sir.
- Oh.
Don't mind if I do.
- Great, great. Carry on?
- Carry on yourself, Alex.
- Thank you.
(orchestral music)
- Economy plus.
For the discerning passengers.
We're not in Kansas anymore,
Toto.
- [Intercom] Ladies and gentlemen,
this is your captain speaking.
We should be leaving Topeka
in the next 10 minutes.
- I stand corrected.
- [Intercom] Looks like we're
going to have a smooth flight.
Trust me, I know the captain,
and he's one smooth guy.
(passenger exhaling)
(Jordan chuckling)
(Jordan laughing)
- Of course knows the captain.
He is the captain.
Move over Colin Mochrie,
there's a new face in the biz.
His name is Captain.
(Jordan giggling)
You have to be in economy
plus to get it, I guess.
(Jordan exhaling)
(quirky music)
Extra foot room.
One inch at least.
Mmm.
Sky Shop Magazine.
Don't mind if I do.
Oh, dog eared for my convenience.
"Lord of the Rings" cups.
"Lord of the Rings" tables.
(shoes thumping)
Holy shiatsu massage!
Economy plus!
It hurts a little,
but I like it!
(Jordan crying)
Rosebud.
(Jordan snoring)
(rain pattering)
(thunder rumbling)
(ominous music)
(creature breathing deeply)
- And I thought I had an upgrade.
(alarm buzzing)
- Lil Wayne y'all.
The Carter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm coming to y'all
straight from Riker's penitentiary beds.
Ya heard man.
Haters out there think I'm playin'.
Think I'm some kind of joke, man.
Young Money.
Check this out right here, man.
I'm the baddest mother (beep)
around this whole prison here bitch.
Ya heard?
Check it out, let's go.
I'm the baddest dude-
(knife stabbing)
(Jordan yelling)
(chain clinking)
(alarm buzzing)
- It's Lil Wayne y'all.
(hip hop music)
Young Money.
Y'all need to watch your back, ya heard?
That's right, yeah yeah yeah.
Cause I'm coming for y'all, you know?
What's up man?
I run this, yeah.
In fact, yo. Let's go.
I'm the baddest,
Where you going, man? Where you going?
Ay ay man, where you going?
You ain't gotta go, ooh!
(knife stabbing)
(Jordan yelling)
(body thumping)
Okay, I see. Pick on the little guy, huh?
Punks.
(knife stabbing)
(Jordan yelling)
- This little ironic
mother (beep) right here.
(door thudding)
(alarm buzzing)
(hip hop music)
(water spattering)
- I don't think we should be
doing this right here, man.
Young Money.
You know what I mean,
there's a time and a place.
(Jordan mumbling)
Man, I ain't scared, yo.
(soap thumping)
(air whooshing)
- Who you gonna call?
(Jordan laughing)
Hi. I'm Ray Parker Jr.,
writer and performer of
the Academy Award nominated
hit single "Ghostbusters,"
from the major motion
picture, "Ghostbusters."
But that's just one song.
I've written so many other
major motion picture theme songs
and submitted them throughout the year.
Now, they're available,
and together for once
specially priced compilation.
Songs like...
♪ You tried to play the game ♪
♪ But it's driving you insane ♪
♪ Jumanji danger in the jungle ♪
♪ Jumanji there's a lion in my house ♪
♪ Come on, Mr. Computer throw me a bone. ♪
♪ I said Lawnmower man
get up off of my lawn ♪
♪ When Armageddon is near
you better get outta here ♪
♪ Lookin' like a deep impact ♪
♪ I ain't afraid of no 'stroid ♪
♪ Watch out behind you
they're trying to find you ♪
♪ Pelican brief ♪
♪ It's getting legal y'all ♪
These songs have only been heard
by the highest level of
industry decision-makers.
But now you can feel like
a Hollywood executive
in your own home.
♪ I see your face off ♪
♪ That guy walking around ♪
♪ It's a face off ♪
♪ That ain't even your face ♪
♪ Passion of the Christ ♪
♪ Get me down off of this cross ♪
♪ You know my daddy is the boss ♪
♪ Disturbia ♪
♪ That's not even a word ♪
♪ Gonna unnerve ya ♪
♪ Now there's a whole lot of kinky ♪
♪ Bet that room is stinky ♪
♪ 50 Shades of Grey ♪
- All right white people
♪ Who's a slave ♪
♪ I'm not a slave uh oh ♪
♪ Twelve years a slave ♪
♪ Whoops ♪
- There's one thing I know,
is that persistence makes perfection.
Sure, Hollywood missed out.
But that doesn't mean you have to.
♪ Down in the basement ♪
♪ What's going on ♪
♪ It's a Apt Pupil ♪
♪ There's a kid and a Nazi down there ♪
(upbeat music)
- [Man] Order now to
receive your free copy of
"Bobby Sings The Twos,"
theme songs to sequels
that were never made.
- You will be in room 237.
And you have free wifi there.
Also, from 6:00 AM to 10:00 AM
every morning there's a
free continental breakfast.
- Oh.
Continental breakfast.
- Yes, from 6:00 AM to 10:00 AM.
- So it's continental then.
- Mm-hmm.
- Very good.
Hey garcon,
one admission for the
continental breakfast.
- You can just help yourself, sir.
- Oh, interesting. European style.
(orchestral music)
(Jordan giggling)
When in Rome.
The forbidden fruit.
Well aren't you a tiny plum?
Well, la di da.
Paper and everything.
And who are you, my little friend?
Not a spoon,
not a fork,
but something in between, a fopoon.
(Jordan chuckling)
What will you think of next, Germany?
(plates clanking)
All the Euro-pine countries lay before me.
Where should I fly to first?
Ah.
The pit of the donut.
Mm, thank you Turkey.
Mm, buckle up.
Let's see where we shall go next.
Ah, the danish.
Clearly from Brussels.
Mm.
Mm!
Hello, Greece.
Where the yogurt flows like water.
(Jordan slurping)
Mm yes.
Like Go-Gurt, but to stay.
So good.
Pulling into Spain.
Mm.
Baked to perfection.
Can you believe it?
It all comes with the room.
Mm.
Oh!
Yes!
I love being in continent.
A delight to the senses,
isn't it my friend?
Isn't it?
Yes!
I'll have what I'm having.
(Jordan crying)
(somber music)
So good.
It's so good.
- Oh, good afternoon, sir,
how can I help you?
- Well, Davis, I will
be staying indefinitely.
- But sir, don't you know
that you've always been here?
(romantic music)
- Really?
- Mm-hmm.
- Continental breakfast?
- Right around the corner.
(upbeat music)
♪ All I want yeah ♪
♪ But I don't need ya ♪